>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Betsy Peterson:
Well, hello everyone.
I am Betsy Peterson, the Director
of the American Folklife Center here
at the Library of Congress, and
on behalf of all of the staff,
I want to welcome you here today.
We are at a Botkin Lecture that is
part of the Botkin Lecture series,
and the Botkin Lecture Series allows
the American Folklife Center to work
with leading scholars, artists,
activists and others involved
in the disciplines of folklore,
folk music, ethomusicology,
oral history and cultural heritage.
It also allows us to
enhance our archives as well.
In 2014, the AFC began to widen
the scope of the Botkin Lectures
to include open mic
sessions like the one
that we're going to
have this afternoon.
And during the open mic sessions,
we invite the public in to listen
to an actual archival interview,
and the center very proudly traces
this type of activity back to 1938
when Allen Lomax, who was also an
employee of the archive at the time,
sat on the stage of the Coolidge
Auditorium right next door
and recorded an interview with
the legendary jazz musician,
Jelly Roll Morton.
For the center and the library,
the Botkin Lecture Series
is also an important part
of our acquisitions activities here.
Each lecture is videotaped and
documented and becomes part
of our permanent collections.
In addition, Botkin events
are later posted as webcasts
on the library's webcast so
that we can share it with people
around the world and
so that it is available
for future generations as well.
So with all of that said,
please turn off any cell
phones at this point.
We would appreciate it.
And now, today -- today is a
very exciting open mic session.
I have the honor of introducing
Mark Moss whose been the editor,
executive director and guiding light
of [inaudible] magazine since 1983.
When people talk about the North
American folk music revival,
the first thing that comes to
mind, of course, are the artists,
musicians, performers, revivalists,
singer songwriters whose artistry
has filled stages, coffee houses,
festivals, vinyl grooves since
the 1950's, but in addition
to the performers or in conjunction
with the performers I should say,
the folk music revival also gave
rise to a complex support network
that included concert and record
producers, venue and club owners,
nonprofits, record labels,
radio stations and announcers,
festival programs, programmers
and on and on and on.
In fact, the folk music
revival was significantly aided,
shaped and documented by this
network and by a whole range
of folk music newsletters,
journals and magazines.
And of course, of all of these,
I think none was more important,
innovative or influential
as Sing Out Magazine.
Today, Sing Out editor, Mark Moss,
will be discussing the
legendary publication
and the seminole role it played in
the American folk song music revival
and also just talk about the
significance and challenges
of folk music journalism today.
To do this, he will be joined
by two AFC staff members,
Nancy Groce and Steve Winick.
So at this point, welcome
Mark, and I'm going to turn
over everything to Nancy and Steve.
>> Nancy Groce: Welcome.
Thank you all so much for coming,
especially to Mark for coming
down from Pennsylvania
to Washington.
Okay, so what I thought we'd do is
talk to you a bit about the history
of Sing Out in particular.
We have some pictures.
Maybe we'll wait until the
middle to show some images
and then talk more broadly
about the role of journalism
in traditional music and folk
music in the United Staes.
>> Stephen Winick: Okay.
>> Nancy Groce: Sounds good?
>> Stephen Winick: Sure.
But for those familiar with the
Jelly Roll Morton interviews
that Betsy talked about, we will
try not to go on for nuine hours,
but if we do, I see a grammy
winning [inaudible] in our future.
>> Mark Moss: I know my
Mom would be [inaudible].
>> Nancy Groce: So tell us
a little bit about yourself.
How did you come to
be editor of Sing Out?
>> Mark Moss: Well, in 1972, well
into the history of Sing Out,
I went to Philadelphia folk
festival, and there was a booth
in the back of the festival that
was set up with decades worth
of back issues of the magazine,
and I kind of sauntered up there,
met a fellow by the
name of Josh Dodson
who was running a group
called [inaudible].
Met a fellow named Josh Dodson
who was running an organization
called Friends of Sing
Out at the time, which is kind
of a fundraising booster support
organization, and I just said --
I was 14 years old and
said, "Hey, can I help?"
So because to me as a -- somebody
who liked folk music who liked music
in general and wanted to
find out where it came from,
what traditions were, was really
getting into a lot of early music.
We'd gone to summer camp and been
brought up on the Weavers and Peter,
Paul and Mary, etc. This was really
-- I felt like I had found my thing.
So I started at that point,
that was my first Sing Out booth
and then throughout the 70's
when I went to college and then
after college ever summer I would
do half dozen or more festivals.
I would load up a car with
all packages of Sing Out,
take them to festivals, sell
subscriptions and things like that.
>> Nancy Groce: [Inaudible]
volunteer?
>> Mark Moss: It was
strictly as a volunteer.
>> Stephen Winick: So you mentioned
the Philadelphia Folk Festival.
Was that a big part of your sort
of induction into folk music
or you were starting to
be involved in the scene?
>> Mark Moss: Well, I saw Arlo
Guthrie at Carnegie Hall in 1970
and I mean, I was already
into the music,
but it was the first
festival that I'd gone to.
And I -- so -- but I already
had a growing interest
in traditional music and blues,
old time music, [inaudible] music
and was sort of looking beyond
the pop folk of the 1960's era
into the more rooted oriented
stuff, and that's what was sort
of surprising to me that there was
something like Sing Out out there.
And honestly a kid growing
up in [inaudible] Valley
in Pennsylvania hadn't really
come across it too much.
I mean, so I became really
quickly and avidly involved
in the magazine at that point.
>> Nancy Groce: And the
magazine itself, just to go back
to the history, was founded when?
Do you want to talk a little
bit about the roots of Sing Out?
>> Mark Moss: At the end of the
second world war, there was a group
of people including notably
Pete Seger, Woody Guthrie,
Allen was involved in those days --
[ Inaudible ]
Paul Rosen was out of the country,
but he was sort of a revered --
I mean, just to back track a
little bit, when these guys
who had been part of the New
York City labor music scene
in the late 30's, early 40's had all
gone off into the second world war
and when they came back, they
sort of got back together again
and created an organization called
Peoples Artist, Incorporated,
which was really sort of a glorified
booking agency, union of artists
who were often affiliated with
the Communist party in the U.S.
and also very involved
with the labor movement.
And they were -- they were acting
as a booking agency for each other
to get both -- to work
collaboratively to do recordings
and to get bookings at labor
meetings, strikes, demonstrations
and things like that,
and they created
in 1946 a newsletter
called People Songs.
First issue was mimiographed
in Oscar Brand's basement
on a mimiograph machine.
But Oscar used to love
to tell that story.
But -- and it went from -- and
Peoples Artist, while it began
as a relatively small group
of musicians in New York City,
developed satellite offices so
that there were offices in Arizona,
San Francisco, Chicago that were
all sharing this national newsletter
that was --
>> Nancy Groce: The Peoples Songs?
>> Mark Moss: The Peoples Songs that
was printing songs in the magazine
as well as news and information
about networking and highlighting
and trying to preserve and share,
classic labor songs and material,
which was really integral to what
they were doing at that point.
In 1948, they got very involved in
the Wallace campaign for president.
And sort of overextended themselves
so after the Wallace campaign was
unsuccessful as history knows,
people saw and found themselves
really strapped for cash
and decided to cancel the magazine.
So they published one final issue,
which was the first
issue of the fourth year.
Each issue was -- the early
ones were just like four pages,
but they got up to
being like 16 pages.
>> Nancy Groce: So
fairly substantial.
They had a couple thousand
subscribers at that point?
>> Mark Moss: I think that they
had like about 1200 subscribers
at its largest distribution
at that point.
And so the final issue was
just a list of names of people
who had been involved
and contributed money
and had been long time subscribers
saying that they were belly up
and they were giving
up and that was it.
And there was an outcry from
the membership saying hey,
wait a minute.
You didn't ask us what you wanted
us to do and if you wanted us
to help the magazine
continue in some way.
And out of those ashes in about
a year later in May of 1950,
the first issue of
Sing Out was formed.
Also, run -- the publishing
entity, the ownership of Sing
Out was Peoples Arts, Incorporated
for the first eight years.
Now, this was like the first
of many near bankruptcies
that this group of people had.
So in the 1950's, it quickly
developed from like a 16 page 5.5
by 8.5 little pamphlet
that they had put
out into a pretty substantial
64 then 128 then 164 page little
magazine, but the 1950's were
like a touch time to be rooted
in the communist party
and the labor movement.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah, talk
about the political situation then
because Peoples Songs come up in
all of the congressional testimony
of people like Pete Seger
and all those folks.
>> Mark Moss: Right.
Well, I mean, the interesting
this is, of course,
because I was born in 1955.
So I was a little young to
have first hand experiences,
but I did have the honor and
benefit of being able to meet
and spend some time with Irwin
Silber who was the editor of Sing
Out after I think it's third
or fourth issue up until 1965.
From his perspective about it --
now, of course, this was years later
and he was done with Sing Out
for many years after I met him.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Mark Moss: But his perspective
of it was that it was strange
that anybody thought that
Sing Out was somehow connected
to the communist party because as
he put it, I never got a phone call
from anybody at party
headquarters telling me what to do.
We just did our thing.
But realistically, I think
it would be irresponsible not
to acknowledge the fact that these
were people that were at the heart
and beginning of both the labor
movement from that period of time,
certainly the beginnings of
the civil rights movement.
Ultimately, women's rights,
anti-Vietnam, anti-war,
all of that stuff was
central to what Sing
Out was at that point in time.
So they -- Irwin's
approach to this --
because my later philosophy
about what I saw Sing Out as
when I became the editor I had some
conversations with Irwin about it.
My feeling was always -- as a
lay person, as a nonpolitician,
but somebody who loves history,
I saw Sing Out as being a folk
music magazine that was influenced
by the times and the
culture and the politics.
Irwin did not see it that way.
He saw it very much as trying
to create a political voice
and doing it by using music
that he saw as a way to connect.
So when he would do -- in the
very first issue of Sing Out,
in fact back into the
Peoples Songs days,
there was always what they called
international music section.
Now this was decades and decades
before anybody every heard the
phrase world music or understood the
connection of vernacular cultures
and traditional musical art forms.
But Irwin saw the power in trying
to identify and make connections
so that people would see their
own struggles and their own needs
in the struggles of
other immigrant groups
and other marginalized
portions to society.
Now, for somebody who loves
folk music, what that ended
up meaning was that you
could come into the magazine
because you were really interested
in reading about Bill Monroe
or finding out about
the collection --
the collecting work that John Jacob
Miles did or something like that.
But the way that it was presented
in Sing Out generally even
if it was subtled up a lot
was presented with sort
of an undercurrent to it that let --
that was shaped by the
political ideology that Irwin
and the other [inaudible] people --
now Pete Seger who was
one of the founders
and honestly the reason
why Sing Out existed,
the reason why Peoples Songs
existed is because Pete went
to Harvard to become a journalist.
That was always his dream.
As I came to find out in a
difficult way as I was taking
over the magazine, that this was --
even though Pete was everybody's
founding father of the folk revival,
certainly my age and probably
a generation before me,
Pete always saw himself as a
journalist that couldn't get a job
in a newspaper so he ended
up being a folk singer
and always wished he
could be an editor.
I mean, jumping ahead for a second,
we -- when we were reforming --
in 1981, Sing Out had
not published a magazine
for about 1.5 year at
that point in time.
And it was clear that the staff
based in the office in New York
and decided that they were
going to pull the plug.
So when I showed up at the
office to load up my car to take
to the Hudson River
revival that year,
they said don't sell any
subscriptions because we're done.
We're out of here.
We're -- so when I got to
the Hudson River revival
which was also an event that was
created and founded by Pete --
this time his organization
[inaudible].
He too me aside.
He was aware of what was going
on and we sort of sat along one
of the heaps of garbage up there.
And he said, "You know, Mark,
somehow, some way even if we've got
to mimeograph this
magazine in somebody's face,
we've got to keep Sing Out going."
So we took a year.
We published an interim newsletter,
which we sent out to the 1800
or so remaining subscribers
[inaudible] Sing Out's mailing list,
fundraising.
He did a series of
concerts raising money.
We paid off the old debt,
and we began putting
out the magazine again.
And when we did the very first
issue, now my background --
I mean, I went to Penn State
University, majored in English,
minored in folklore, but I
had no experience doing this.
I had been working as
a union electrician
for about four years
before this occurred.
So when I put out my first
issue of the magazine,
it was rough shall we say.
I knew nothing about -- it
was much room for improvement.
But Pete came to that first board
meeting,and we had assembled a board
of directors that would
run a new nonprofit
that we had created
to publish Sing Out.
And they were all musicians, and
Pete came to that first meeting
and like steam was coming out of
his ears because he hated the fact
that I had put type on top of the
block print that he had procured
to do the front cover of Sing
Out and didn't like how some
of the things were edited
and how they were laid out.
And he said, "Here's my idea.
What we're going to do is
we're going to rent a truck,
and we're going to load all
the file cabinets and a couple
of desks in theback of the truck.
And you're going to
drive from city to city.
In each city, you're going to
roll off the back of the truck
and people will walk by and will
say what are you doing in there?
And then you'll say we're
doing a folk music magazine.
Would you like to help?"
>> Stephen Winick:
That's Pete all right.
>> Mark Moss: And I said, Pete,
if you want to do that,
you can do that.
But I'm not doing that.
And luckily there were other people
on the board at that time who stood
up for me and Pete quit the
board for I think the first of --
in my tenure a half dozen times
over the course of that --
the 30 or so years
until Pete passed.
>> Stephen Winick: I think
Pete's father would have done
that if it had been him.
Charlie would have done that,
driven around in a truck.
>> Mark Moss: Yeah, yeah.
Absolutely.
I have no doubt that
Pete would have done it
if he didn't have those pesky
tour commitments and things.
But getting back to the history of
things, so when Sing Out revived
in 1950, this was sort of like the
beginning of the Hugh Act period
of what was going on here, and
pretty much everybody affiliated
with Peoples Artists ended up
getting either named or subpoenaed
or questioned or blacklisted,
and in one way it created a
comaraderie amongst people,
and the growth of people that were
involved in Peoples Artists and Sing
Out in those days grew to
include people like Norman Lear
and of course Paul Robson came back
briefly out of exile and was sort
of worshipped amongst the
staff at Sing Out and stuff.
But careful looking would see
that while the first seven'ish,
almost eight years of Sing
Out included a Peoples Artist
publication underneath the mast head
and as theownership, it disappeared
by the end of the 1950's and sort
of quietly Peoples Artists
ceased to exist and Irwin Silber
who was not a musician himself but
certainly not a performing musician
but a pretty able organizer
and entrepreneur took ownership
and took over Sing Out.
He also had partial involvement or
[inaudible] had partial involvement
in ownership in Sing Out during
those days, though that sort of --
>> Nancy Groce: [Inaudible]
ran [inaudible]'s recordings,
which are now -- it was taken over
by the Smithsonian in the late 70's
and now Smithsonian [inaudible].
>> Mark Moss: And then as
the 50's came to a close,
Irwin also started a publishing
company called Oak Publications,
which was responsible
for many of most
of the real important
collections and instruction books
and song books and stuff.
So he -- Sing Out would
share offices with --
on and off from the mid 50's
up until the late 1960's
with some combination of
[inaudible] Publications, whatever.
In 1965, Irwin who had already begun
doing a lot more overt political
writing had decided that
the ship had kind of sailed
from folk music being a way to
make his political statement
and kind of receded from it.
He sold Oak Publications to music
sales and ended up selling Sing
Out separately to a cooperative
of people including Manny Solomon
of Vanguard, Mo, Howard
Leventhal, Pete, and they formed
yet another corporation that
was putting out a magazine
that was now starting off
saddled with about a $20,000 debt
because all of these people had put
money in the pot, which bought Irwin
out and Irwin went off
to work for The Guardian.
And [inaudible] became the
editor for about 18 months
or so during that period of time.
And Sing Out really
radically made a shift
because Happy's orientation
was not Irwin's.
Happy's orientation was much more
-- because that was really --
it was right after Happy's tenure
when I discovered the magazine.
So he was much more into being
excited by the connection
of traditions into contemporary
and sort of the evolution
of the folk process
and that kind of stuff
that had always been the dressing of
what Sing Out was, but the politics
of it sort of took a
different role in the --
in what the magazine was doing.
So Happy tried to keep things
going for a couple of years
and then what we had was a
series of semi catastrophies
and financial difficulties mostly
having to do with the financial debt
that they had during this point
in time while they were putting
out sort of a glorified fanzine
in an era that was not a DIY era.
So while Sing Out during
its most prominent era --
period during those early
1960's years leading
up to Irwin being disenchanted
had its --
its subscription base
had risen to I think --
it's difficult to tell
because everybody lies
on their second class distribution
that they post in the magazine
but it seemed to be
somewhere between about 12,000
and 15,000 copies were being
printed at its highest moment
up to that point in time.
But by the time the early
70's had rolled around,
it had shrunk back again to down
to just a couple of thousand,
and it was difficult to figure
out how to continue doing it.
The format of the magazine changed.
They tried in the mid 1970's.
They issued a flexi disk in
every other issue of the magazine
that included just the
first verse and chorus
of the songs that were
being printed.
But there was a lot of editorial
turnover during that period of time
so would go for like
a couple of issues
where it would be very
much connected,
and there'd be thematic issues
were put out for instance
in the bicentennial year
that were each talking
about different immigrant traditions
or Native American cultures
and stuff like that.
And then there were
other periods of times
where it took a very pointed dive
toward the uber political and what
that ended up doing was the
audience that was there,
the people who were showing
up for the politics would go why
are you covering this other stuff?
And the people that were showing
up for traditional music were
saying what do you mean Puerto
Rican independence?
So they continued to have
problems which led up to the end
of the 1970's -- 1980
was the final issue
that the New York team
put out as a magazine.
>> Stephen Winick: It's
interesting because it kind
of shows two different
ways in which politics
and music interact in a magazine.
So you're talking about
people wanting
to cover overtly political things
like Puerto Rican independence,
but at the same time that shift
in the bicentennial [inaudible]
immigrant cultures was a political
thing in the United
States at that time,
though not perceived as political.
For the most part,
perceived as cultural.
So Sing Out was covering
both of those things,
and you're saying it was
maybe a little uncomfortable
for the audience?
>> Mark Moss: Yeah.
I mean, look, when we went
through that period of time in 1982
when Pete and I were editing that
newsletter and we were asking
for input about what do you want
Sing Out to be going forward kind
of discussion, ultimately what
we found out was is that the base
of people that we had that
were still reading the magazine
at that time were in -- were --
it was sort of like five
Jews at a dinner party.
There were 12 opinions.
And --
>> Stephen Winick: No, you're wrong.
>> Mark Moss: So ultimately
we decided two main things.
I mean, we as this
forming board came together
to create the nonprofit
that would go
on to publish Sing Out since then.
Was first and foremost
was we wanted Sing
Out to be a folk music
magazine connecting traditional
and contemporary folk music
and looking at how it interacts
with our every day lives and helped
people make that music a part
of how they did the
things that they did.
But music was going to be
the driving force behind it.
We would look to the music
first and follow the politics
that are always coupled and inherent
in what true community vernacular
orally transmitted music is
because by its very nature,
if you're regionally trying
to celebrate your culture, you
are making a political statement
in a day and age that doesn't
honor that and doesn't celebrate
that in that kind of a way.
But the second part of it is, to be
fair, is we weren't sort of trying
to be fair or balanced
about our politics either.
We have a history of coming out
of leftist political movements.
And that's where we stayed.
So -- but by -- I think by
shifting that focus by deciding
that the magazine was going to
always try to be a smorgasbord
to a certain extent and
to include some politics,
some stuff about just the community,
some stuff about the history
of music, some stuff about how to
play the music, in each issue --
and try to do that -- we were
able to retain that membership
and build our subscriber
base again by the late 80's,
early 90's back up to about 15,000.
Now, of course, that was the 1990's
and the beginnings of the internet.
>> Nancy Groce: In the meantime,
the office had moved
to Pennsylvania, right?
>> Mark Moss: Right.
After the 1981 Hudson River
revival, some friends of mine
and I rented a U-Haul
truck, drove up to New York,
parked across the street
from 505 Eighth Avenue
where we were subletting -- Sing Out
was subletting 2.5 rooms from WBAL,
the Pacifica radio station in New
York, and we loaded up the truck
like to the ceiling with
all the magazines, books,
recordings, file cabinets.
And then I went out, got in the
truck and tried to pull out,
but the entire back of the
truck was on the wheels.
So we went and rented another
truck and emptied out the one
into the other one, and
we moved to Pennsylvania.
At that point in time, we really
didn't know what was going on.
We just knew we couldn't
continue to pay rent to WBAI
because we were months
in arrears at that point.
We owed the printer about
$12,000 which in 1982 money was --
>> Stephen Winick:
Pretty substantial, yeah.
>> Mark Moss: Pretty substantial.
>> Nancy Groce: And
so you went down to --
where you're originally
from -- to Easton?
>> Mark Moss: I grew up in the
Lehigh Valley so we went to Easton,
unloaded the truck into the basement
of my friend's bicycle shop,
you know Genesis Bicycles
still there if you want to --
>> Nancy Groce: Give
them business, yes.
>> Mark Moss: And then like a little
over a year after that in December
of 1982, we published a final
issue of the newsletter and said
that we would be -- in the spring we
would be putting out the first issue
of a new revitalized Sing Out
published by Sing Out Corporation,
this new nonprofit that we
had formed and then we set
up an office upstairs from a
friend of mine's woodworking shop
and got ready and put
that first issue out.
>> Nancy Groce: And then you
moved again many years later
into your building
in Bethlehem, right?
>> Mark Moss: Yeah.
We've moved twice.
We moved to another place in
Bethlehem about five years later
and then about four years after
that, we purchased a property
on Fourth Street in Bethlehem,
and we set things up there.
>> Nancy Groce: You have a
resource center and a library and --
a library in a resource
center and offices there?
>> Mark Moss: Yeah.
Pretty soon after we formed a new
nonprofit, the mission as I sort
of loosely mentioned of the new
corporation was the preserving
and encouraging traditional
contemporary folk music, that stuff.
And but shortly after we had created
the bylaws for the organization,
we knew that the magazine was
just going to be sort of one arm
of what we were trying
to do to do the work
that was ultimately the
mission, and we very quickly
because there was a bunch of stuff
that we had moved from New York
that was interesting, we decided
that we would also create a
collection or a resource center,
not trying to compete with
something like the library
because we were really
trying to include access
to commercially released material,
not so much archival material
that -- but to try to create
a collection of recordings,
photographs, magazines, books and
[inaudible] that had been part
of the process of making Sing
Out for the previous 30 years.
>> Nancy Groce: Maybe just take
a minute to look at some images
and maybe, Steve, if you could --
>> Stephen Winick: Oh, sure.
>> Nancy Groce: Run that.
While Steve -- I has about a dozen
images of Sing Out over the years,
but I did want to ask you about the
fact that from the very first --
actually Peoples Songs, there have
always been songs included both
music and text, and a
really impressive list.
Just in the 50's alone
Sing Out was the journal
that introduced most Americans
to things like [inaudible],
16 Tons, Pretty Boy Floyd.
This Land is Your Land
was first printed
in Sing Out in the 1953 edition.
Roll On Columbia, Putting
on the Style,
Michael Rolled the Boat Ashore.
>> Mark Moss: The very first issue
of Sing Out, which is what gave Sing
Out it's name was to have --
>> Nancy Groce: Which
comes from where?
>> Mark Moss: To have a song
actually If I Had a Hammer as --
which was subsequently
recorded by Peter, Paul and Mary
and that's how the name got changed.
>> Nancy Groce: And it was written
by Lee Hayes and Pete Singer.
>> Mark Moss: Lee Hayes
and Pete Singer.
And the third verse which
was if I had a song,
I'd sing out for freedom,
for justice.
So that's where Sing
Out got its name from,
and its always been an essential
aspect of what Sing Out is,
which is why probably I would
guess that even during my tenure
at least 75 percent of Sing
Out readers were musicians,
not necessarily most of the
time not professional musicians,
but people who liked making
music, not just reading
about music or consuming music.
And that was a big part of what --
of how we framed our mission was do
it, and then not to like go on stage
and get the spotlights and the
mics in front of you but to do it
in your kitchen when you're
putting your baby to sleep
when you're doing your dishes,
when you're working in the garden,
when you're getting together with
friends to have music be a part
of how you socially interact.
>> Nancy Groce: This
is Peoples Songs.
This is the first anniversary issue?
>> Mark Moss: Right.
And there you could see Paul Robson
towering in the middle there with --
and with a number of the other
people who were involved in the Sing
Out staff during that point in time.
I think it's Betty Sanders
[inaudible] stage left.
Your right.
And so that was some of the
propulsion that happened in that era
of -- I mean, those early years
were really -- so I've heard --
were quite exciting as far as --
Sing Out wasn't just plotting along.
It was growing and growing with
each subsequent issue as you look
over those early issues in the
magazine, it was really interesting
to see it grow in the number of
pages and the breadth of coverage.
>> Nancy Groce: Yeah,
this is a early --
this actually was in the mid 60's?
>> Mark Moss: This was --
>> Nancy Groce: '65.
>> Mark Moss: 1965.
One of the things that we found in
our collection when we were moving
from New York, I mentioned that
because you can see Johnny Cash
on the cover there, there was a
quite famous dressing down that Sing
Out editor Irwin Silber did to --
as an open letter to Bob Dillon
after Dillon had plugged
in at Newport.
But it wasn't -- it's
like sort of a misnomer
that it was the folks seen getting
pissed off with him for plugging
in because that wasn't
Irwin's thing at all.
Irwin was dressing down for
abandoning his politics.
And subsequent to that because
this was right around the time
that Dillon had gone to
Nashville and had begun --
>> Nancy Groce: With the
recording [inaudible].
>> Mark Moss: He met Johnny Cash,
and they became good friends.
It was also around the time
that Johnny Cash shall we say was
experiencing the 1960's version
of drug abuse.
So he had handwritten a -- on
notebook paper a six page letter
to Bob Dillon that I think
what this was in response to --
Sing Out during this point in time
would regularly maybe every couple
of years do what they called a
symposium where they would reach
out to a number of people in --
that were musicians or scholars
or forklorists in the folk music
community and pose a question
to them, and each person would write
back with like a little paragraph
or set of paragraphs
about something.
And I think Johnny's
response back was meant
as a response to a symposium.
I don't really know for sure,
but I can't imagine why else he
would think to send such a thing
to Sing Out, but it was
barely comprehensible stream
of consciousness, bizarre
like -- letter to Johnny Cash.
I'm sorry.
Letter from Johnny Cash to Bob
Dillon essentially telling him
to stay the course and that he
loved his new stuff and that sort
of fighting back against
Irwin's thing.
Now, Dillon to this day still has
a craw or a thorn in his claw,
whatever the correct
expression is about Sing Out.
I mean, I know that in
his memoir that he put
out a few years ago
he devoted half a --
to talking about how he would just
carry around that issue of Sing
Out because he was going
to punch Irwin Silber
in the nose if there were songs --
>> Nancy Groce: But Sing
Out, which was the first
to really publish Dillon and
draw attention to Dillon.
>> Mark Moss: Yeah, Broadside was
actually very early on as well,
but Sing Out -- I mean, throughout
its history, Sing Out has published
over 5000 traditional and
contemporary folk songs,
and it was an early place where
it covered and published new songs
and songs from the repertoire of
Dillon, Baez, Paxton, [inaudible],
all of the stars of
what came to be known
as the folk revival that inspired.
It was the first place
where interviews
with Mississippi John [inaudible]
published and things like that.
It was really an essential
Bible for people that were
in the scene during that.
>> Stephen Winick: And I
think the printing of songs
in the magazine is a point that
should be emphasized because it's
so different from any other
music magazine in that regard
and as you say, it had
to do with the fact
that the readers were expected
to actually do it at some point.
>> Mark Moss: Sing Out
was around since 1950.
Broadside didn't start
until 1960, ten years later.
But there was like a long, long
list of other magazines from --
there was a Boston Broadside,
[inaudible] Review, [inaudible].
There were all these other magazines
that sort of erupted as part
of the interest in folk
music as popular music,
but they were all consumed this, by
this, you're the stars of the music.
It wasn't about sort of breaking
it down and connecting it
into the history and roots
of where the music came from.
I mean, a lot of the people who were
the biggest commercial successes
and stars of that period of time,
even people like the Kingston Trio
were using folk music collected
by folklores and stored at the
library, that they were coming
in here, pouring through the
old manuscripts, arranging it
and making the stuff jaunty
and like they would sing songs
about people being
murdered and hung with --
as [inaudible] happy sing-a-longs.
But -- and sort of
almost disconnecting it
from what the root is,
but there were also people
like the New Lost City Ramblers
which included Pete's half
brother Michael and John Kohn
who were looking back to the
roots of the music and trying
to preserve it in a more serious
way and that was at its crux.
I mean, interestingly Sing Out
never covered Peter, Paul and Mary.
The only time that they
mentioned the Kingston Trio was
in a negative way.
Even somebody like Burl Ives
who I think mostly got the
super short [inaudible]
because he named names in front
of [inaudible] so he became sort
of enemy one of the staff
of Sing Out at that time.
But much of the best known
of the folk revival pop people
were not really covered until sort
of the next generation
of people came along,
and those people were often
if not always being very,
very mostly inspired
by Pete and Woody.
Woody was very much part
of the community of people
who started Peoples Songs, but
he was already getting ill.
By the time Sing Out was around,
he was already well on his way
to being incapacitated, and so I
know that for decades through --
more than a decade of my
tenure Woody had made --
had sent some letter to Sing Out
that somebody had found in the files
at some point in time
where he said something --
one little issue of
Sing Out is worth more
than all the dopey dreamy garbage
dreamed up along every Broadway
of this world or something along
-- quoting off the top of my head.
But he was a tremendous
supporter of Sing Out
and of course Harold
Leventhal who was his manager
and became Pete's manager was
integrally involved in Sing
Out throughout its tenure.
>> Stephen Winick: I have to say
that I don't want to get too far
into the weeds, but I'm
fascinated by this cover of Sing
Out that we have on the screen
right now for three reasons.
I mean, we're talking about
the politics of the magazine
and so students at Berkeley
being the feature on the bottom
but then I don't know if people
can read this because it's
in pretty small type but along the
type under the [inaudible] magazine,
it says with international section,
which has its own kind of cultural
but also political side
and then the photo --
the two photos of Johnny Cash and
Muddy Waters that are sort of edited
to almost make it look like
they're standing next to each other
on the same stage,
although they're not.
>> Mark Moss: I think
if you [inaudible].
>> Stephen Winick: Okay, yeah, yeah.
But still it's sort of -- all of
that has -- it's sort of political.
>> Mark Moss: There was
no photoshop in 1965.
>> Stephen Winick: So
let's advance, yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: Just what Sing
Out looked like in the 1970's.
This is 1973.
>> Mark Moss: Of course,
that was Aunt Molly Jackson
who was a very important organizer
for UMW, United Mine Workers.
There was not another magazine
during this point in time
that you have been able to read
something about Aunt Molly Jackson.
I mean, I'm sure there were
scholarly journals writing
about her, but these were -- that's
the kind of focus that Sing Out had
that there was no other
magazine that was --
>> Nancy Groce: Looking
back to the roots of --
>> Stephen Winick: And many
of her recordings are here
in our archive we should say.
>> Nancy Groce: This is a reprint.
This is actually '59 to
'64, which is collected.
>> Mark Moss: Starting
in the late --
in the late 1950's
because especially during
the early days of Sing Out.
They would do very short --
they would know how many
issues they would need,
and they would print them.
So almost a decade into things,
and they were approaching
their tenth anniversary.
They decided they would
put out little pocketbooks,
5.5 by 8.5 staple binded
saddle stitched pamphlets
that were just songs that
were selected from Sing Out.
And there were 12 that were
done that went from 1959
up until 1972 actually, and we
collected them and released them
in two different volumes.
Now this is like from
the late 1980's.
>> Stephen Winick: And for
the musicians in the room,
I'll also read out the
small print on this
because it's a great indication
that people were really
thinking about using this.
This book has been
specially bound to lie flat
and stay open for easy use.
People who are musicians will
know how important that can be
or you can't use the book, yeah.
>> Mark Moss: I should also mention
that that book was also toward the
beginning of another sort of shift
or arm in what we did with
Sing Out in the 1980's.
One of the things --
those first couple
of years were really
pretty much a struggle.
We were just trying to
get back on our feet
to get things publishing again and
sort of going through the archive
and looking through some of the
old financial records and talking
to people from the early days of the
magazine, it quickly became apparent
to me that at least for
the -- during the last --
the 1966 to 1968 period, Sing
Out was almost being wholly
supported by Oak Publications.
Oak Publications was
paying its rent,
and it was supplementing its
printing, and lots of issues during
that time would come and there'd be
like a three or four page section
in the middle of the magazine,
which would be all ads
for Oak Publications
books that were paid for.
So Sing Out was subsisting as a
periodical by riding on the crest
of people that wanted to buy these
books of the hard sitting songs
for hard hit people, and
the Vietnam song book
or whatever the Oak
Publications was coming out.
So we decided as a board that we
wanted to create a publishing arm
for Sing Out and Sing Out
Publications was born.
>> Nancy Groce: We'll get to that
in a minute with Rise Up Singing.
Let's -- is this when you started to
do inserts for -- or this is just --
>> Mark Moss: That
was some years later.
This was -- one of the
things we were doing
from a promotional purpose is
we'd go to a record company.
We'd say hey, we'll
run an ad for you
if you give us a couple hundred
copies of a sampler for your label,
which we will then use as
premium so somebody could sign
up for a subscription to
the magazine for I think
at the time we were still like
$18 a year or something like that,
and you'll get a free CD.
So it was just like a --
my little entrepreneurship.
>> Nancy Groce: I just
pulled some covers
to what the more contemporary
Sing Out looks like.
So it went color and
full size in color.
>> Mark Moss: We actually
didn't go quite full size.
We went to a 7 and 3/4 by 9,
not 8.5 by 11 kind of size.
Don't ask me why.
I think [inaudible] reader was that
size, and we wanted to be cool.
But newsstands hated us because
we weren't the right size to fit
on the newsstand correctly.
I think Dirty Linen wrote when we
did the press release about us going
from the 5.5 to 8.5 to
that size was that Sing
Out is now almost as big as we are.
>> Stephen Winick: That
sounds like Dirty Linen, yeah.
We're very irreverent.
>> Mark Moss: And this of course
is the final print issue of Sing
Out that came out about
two years ago.
>> Stephen Winick: We'll point
out that this photo is
actually in our archive as well.
That's a Robert Corwin photo from
his collection, and beautiful photo
of Pete Seger's banjo which says
this machine surrounds hate and then
under his arm, it says and
forces it to surrender.
>> Mark Moss: This was sort
of our tribute to Pete issue.
>> Nancy Groce: He had just died.
And this is --
>> Mark Moss: There's our
Sing Out headquarters.
If you want to come to a place
where it's filled floor to ceiling
on three floors with anything
-- we have about 40,000 albums,
about 5000 -- 5 or 6000 books.
I think about 10,000 CD's.
About nine legal size
lateral file cabinets filled
with photos that's many
of the great photographers
from the folk revival
area, video, even VHS.
>> Nancy Groce: We have VHS here.
We'll talk.
And that's in Bethlehem,
Pennsylvania.
This is what your online
presence looks like.
This is for your resource
center, but you have a website.
>> Mark Moss: We have a website,
and since we stopped publishing
the magazine, we do news
and reviews on a regular basis.
We also host several blogs most
notably Murder Ballad Monday
which every Monday does an
in depth sort of discussion
about a traditional or
contemporary song that in
which somebody gets
murdered or maimed.
>> Nancy Groce: It's very popular.
>> Mark Moss: It's very popular, and
you can subscribe to it for free,
get an RSS feed telling
you when [inaudible],
and it always includes lots of
sort of academ'ish wrangling
of different things about a
song, but it also includes tons
of audio sources from Spotify or
Youtube of all different versions
of people with doing those
songs and often there's --
some of the columns will deal
with a specific murder or incident
and then cover various
songs that covered it
so there will be newspaper
clippings and old historical photos
as well as the audio sources.
We also host a syndicated radio show
that's heard in about 30 markets
across the U.S. and that also
is available as a podcast
that you can subscribe to through
the website and coming this summer,
the site's going to be expanding
a lot because the entire archive
of Peoples Songs, Sing Out
and Broadside will all be
completely digitized and available
for public reading and --
>> Nancy Groce: And just before we
go to questions, I wanted to point
out I think the next
slide is Rise Up Singing.
Can you talk a little bit about this
because this has been kind of --
become the Bible for singing
groups throughout the country.
>> Mark Moss: As I was mentioning
earlier about the board deciding
that we wanted to create a
publishing arm very early on.
One of the things that we
used to do is there was a --
there was a folk music
fake book that was released
without anybody's permission called
Wins of the People that included --
it was put together by a group of
Quakers from the Philadelphia area
and included everything
from Broadway show tunes,
Beatles tunes to child ballads,
classic weaver's material
and old time music and
all kinds of stuff.
It was -- that book
was about 750 songs.
And we -- I went to the people
who I knew had published
that original book
because Sing Out used to --
that used to be a premium
that Sing Out would offer.
If you subscribe to Sing Out, you
can have a copy of [inaudible],
and we always sold it
at the Sing Out booth.
So I went to them and
said what do you think?
If we went and we got
permission from the writers
for the copywritten material that
would be in there to do a book
like this so we could
do it above ground?
And we ended up making a
list of about 1400 songs
of which we got permission where --
about half of the materials
in the public domain
and the other half is
copywritten material that we went
to either the musicians or
the publishers and agreed --
and they either agreed to
donate the songs to Sing
Out to help us do the book or took a
most favored nation tiny [inaudible]
to allow us to do it.
So ultimately the book
has 1200 songs.
It's broken up into sections
like by subject matter
and then alphabetically within
that and it's just lyrics
and guitar chords and
the idea was --
I mean, very much a part of
our mission and why we saw it
as being the perfect
first book for us
to do was we wanted
everybody to sing.
When you get together, but a lot
of times people didn't know
what the lyrics to stuff was
and they didn't have it
in a compact kind of a way
so we did this book spiral
bound and we market -- and --
took us about three years of prep
work to secure all the permissions
and to do the typesetting and the
editing and stuff to put together.
And this -- I think
it came out in 1987.
>> Stephen Winick: Not all the
issues of it are spiral bound
because I've got one of the
regular bound ones and again --
>> Mark Moss: We had a
publishing distribution deal
with both a book publisher
and a music trade distributor,
and they both insisted
that they knew better
and that it needed to have a spine.
So -- but Peter Blood
and Annie Patterson
who were the brainchildren
behind the project knew
that the way people used it was they
wanted it to be flat or to be able
to fold it back on itself when you
were using it in this kind of way.
So that was always the main
way that we printed the book,
but there were perfect bound
versions of it that were put
out for maybe like the first -- we
even did like a hard bound version
of it, which was completely
useless because it doesn't --
it just doesn't stay open.
>> Stephen Winick: However, it's
helpful for libraries like ours
where its got to be on a shelf
and people have to see it.
So I guess there's a place for it.
>> Mark Moss: There is that.
But we were making it
to be in people's --
the front pocket in people's guitar
cases, not on library shelves.
>> Stephen Winick: And I have
to say I've been to many,
many community things all over
the place that use this book
because it's so handy to
have the words and chords
for all these songs together.
>> Mark Moss: We --
there are a little
over 800,000 copies
of this book in print.
>> Nancy Groce: And
[inaudible] subsequent book.
>> Stephen Winick:
Hey, look at that.
>> Mark Moss: We -- Peter and Annie
did this book with Hal Leonard.
We were not involved in it because
this book came out sort of already
when we were beginning
to enter the --
our latest extreme
financial distress period.
But we do sell the
book on our website.
And this is another 1200 songs
that weren't in the other book.
So if you buy one,
you need the other.
>> Nancy Groce: So Rise Up
really has become a Bible
for public community
singing in this country.
So we can go on and on because you
just have so many great stories,
but perhaps we can take a couple
of questions from the audience.
Questions?
>> Stephen Winick:
Is there a roving mic
for the -- is there a wireless mic?
>> Nancy Groce: We'll
repeat their question.
[ Inaudible ]
Your funding.
>> Mark Moss: Me.
Well, Sing Out -- even though we
are a nonprofit, a 501c3 charity,
we're an educational institution
as we're officially called.
We've never brought in more than
about 15 percent of our income
from contributions, and the rest
is either from subscriptions
or book sales or other work that
we've done through advertising sales
in the magazine when we were
still publishing the magazine
and that kind of stuff.
Of late, if you know where
our income is, please tell me.
>> Nancy Groce: But you
would take contributions.
>> Mark Moss: Yes, we do.
We have done some grant
writing over the years.
We received a small
-- some small support
from the NEA in the early 1990's.
There was an organization called
the [inaudible] Foundation,
which I don't think still exists.
But they provided the initial
seed money that allowed us
to begin shelving, indexing
and cataloging the resource
center in the late 1980's.
And the Pennsylvania Council on
the Arts has been supportive,
[inaudible] and there's also some
other smaller private foundations
that we've gone to.
>> Nancy Groce: Other questions?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Stephen Winick: So the
question is how technology
and particularly the internet have
affected folk music, journalism
and publishing and whether that's
impacting Sing Out do you think more
than other magazines
that are still surviving?
>> Mark Moss: Well, it's
dramatically affected it
because for the most part even
people that say that they love Sing
Out I would be willing to
bet that a large number
of them don't have a clue
that we haven't put a
magazine out since late 2014.
So because people are getting
their information from all kinds
of other places, they
know they like our mission
and they support the idea of Sing
Out, but they're not really willing
or interested in paying
for it anymore.
Whether it be Youtube,
Spotify, Apple Music,
you don't need a reviewer to
tell you when a new record is out
or what you think of it
because you can listen to it
and make a decision for yourself.
Now, as a nearly life-long music
journalist, I don't think that that
that works as well for a number of
different reasons including none
of these online sources
provide you information
about who the musicians are
that are playing, who wrote
or didn't write the material, what
the history of the material is,
often the lyrics are
inaccessible and unavailable.
But at the end of the day,
I've got a reality that's based
on several different things.
The -- in the early 2000's,
Sing Out's largest newsstand
distributor went belly up.
These were people that were
distributing in Border's books
as well as many other distribution.
I would say probably 2/3 of our
distribution was sold in that way.
Now we were already
in a circumstance
where if we turned a profit
from material that was sold
on the newsstand, it was a surprise.
It was more advertising
that hopefully somebody would see
an issue of Sing Out at a Border's
and pick it up and
then they'd subscribe
and then we can make some money
because by the time there was
a 50 percent wholesale discount
and then there was -- we had to pay
to ship it there and shelving fees
and all these other kinds of things,
we were barely getting
enough money just to pay
for the printing of the magazine.
What would happen was is that
part of the industry like --
it evaporated in a protracted way.
So when they went belly
up, they stiffed us
for a significant five figure
amount of money, which I suppose
if you're building casinos or big
giant buildings with T's on them
or something, $50,000
isn't a lot of money,
but that was like a huge
amount of money for us.
And it created a cycle that
forced us into other kinds
of decisions and things
that went on.
The UK magazines had a completely
different distribution model
where distributors in the UK buy
the magazines and then resell them.
We put -- everything that was on
newsstands was consignment for us.
So when we got stiffed,
not only were we stiffed
for like what didn't sell, we
were stiffed for what did sell.
So it wasn't just that money
that we thought was coming
in stopped coming in.
It was that money that we put out
of pocket wasn't getting reimbursed.
And that set a number of
other things in motion
that just weren't recoverable
for us.
This is also -- we're
also in a situation
where Sing Out's a
folk music magazine.
I mean, I wish that the publisher
of Newsweek was sitting next to me.
It would help me make this case.
But people share -- not only
are these direct music resources
out there that if you want to
go and search them to find them,
but Facebook, Myspace, Youtube,
all these places where people,
the social networking stuff.
So if I hear some music and I like
it, I share it with all my friends.
So the response ended up -- and
there was also the emergence
of content information web
development so that many
of our writers like yourself,
people are writing reviews for us
or writing articles for us,
they just created their
own Wordpress site,
and they published it themselves
and they have control over it.
So there's like a ton
of those things.
Now some of them we've been able
to entice those people to come
and network under the Sing Out
umbrella, but many of them go well,
why do I want to do that?
I'll just do it myself.
[ Inaudible ]
>> That is kind of
a question, though,
whether the internet then
provides any kind of opportunity
for an organization like Sing Out.
We've talked about the blogs like
[inaudible] Monday that get put
under the Sing out umbrella.
Does that help Sing Out
at all do you think?
And can other --
>> Mark Moss: Well, it
does -- here's the thing.
We monthly receive about 50,000
unique hits on the Sing Out website.
These are people coming to read
news, reviews, blogs, other things.
But these are people that are coming
there and they're doing it for free.
And converting that into a way of
beig able to generate the income,
even the pay for the basic
costs of running the website,
the annual subscription fee
and the SSL certificates
and renewing our URL's
and things like that is --
that money's got to
come from some place.
Not to forget the fact that
when we're publishing reviews
that are written by somebody
as somebody that's coming
from a tradition of worker's rights,
I don't like running the stuff
and not being able to pay people.
So we were trying to pay a small,
infinitesibly small amount of money
to somebody who writes a review
and puts it on the Sing Out site,
but there's not a way
of making that happen.
Now, what we're hoping
to do going forward,
I mentioned that there's
a digitizing project
which is underway now that's going
to make available the complete run
of Sing Out, Peoples Songs and
Broadside, we're going to put
that behind amost pay wall that --
for a subscription basis of
$1.99 a month or something
like that you get access
to all of it for as long
as you're a member kind of a thing,
and if there's enough support
for that to occur, we can
maybe look toward expanding it.
Now at the end of the day, I know it
doesn't really answer your question
because you don't like
computers and --
>> Nancy Groce: Maybe on that
note because we want to end --
we have to wrap pretty soon.
Where would one go online
to find out about Sing Out?
>> Mark Moss: Singout.org.
>> Nancy Groce: Okay.
I want to thank Mike Moss for coming
and for a really interesting talk.
And thank you all for coming.
>> Mark Moss: Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.